you're not ready
he's not going to stop not
until he's taken everyone
your friends have lost
Welcome back everyone netflix dropped a brand new
stranger things season 4 volume 2 trailer we'll
break it down there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos they totally
did the thing they put the kate bush song in
the trailer everybody predicted that would happen
after episode four blew up with the kate bush song
k bush came out in real life and said she's really
happy to see their songs super popular again stuff
like this happens all the time with nostalgic
series like stranger things which trades on a lot
of 80s tropes like every time a new guardians of
the galaxy movie comes out like guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 we'll have a bunch of new songs from
the 70s all those songs will hit the charts again
after the movie comes out we should call the theme
of volume 2 still running up that hill but there's
a bunch of brand new footage here vecna has come
back into the normal dimension from the upside
down big reminder too there are only two episodes
in volume 2. episode 8 is titled papa in episode
9 the finale is titled the piggyback obviously
papa refers to brenner because that's what number
11 used to call him i'm sure some of the other
kids called him papa as well too maybe number one
also used to call him papa but it sounds like
when brenner was developing the program based
on what happened with number one like he said
that he developed the program because he wasn't
able to control him like he branded him number
one when he developed the program and that's
when he put the self-destruct device in him so i
think as much as it's a reference to 11 calling
him papa is also a reference to number one also
calling him papa with a more negative connotation
he's always been portrayed as something of a dirt
bag so i did think it was kind of weird when we
saw eleven referring to him as papa again during
season four even though it seems like she kind
of resents him and everything that he did she
still treats him kind of like a father figure
which is kind of messed up like he's probably the
most messed up father figure in stranger things
just because of the way he treated all these
children as test subjects but you could post all
your theories in the comments below what you think
the title of the finale the piggyback refers to
like what is piggybacking and is this a reference
to the mindflayer piggybacking on number one on
his way into the regular dimension if you missed
my last trailer video i also clarified what the
producers what the actors have said about how the
upside down was initially created they said that
it was always meant to look like this place here
it was called the nether before they called it the
upside down they actually started to call it the
upside down during season one after fans started
watching the series and just termed it the upside
down so they said okay why don't we just make that
cannon it's called the upside down now but when
she pushes number one into this place it looks
like this mostly until you get to the events of
season one in the early 80s she opens the mother
gate and they say what happened when she did that
is that both of the dimensions started to overlap
more fully and combine into one like the fact that
the gate was left open allowed that to happen more
and more so like the longer the gate is open or
the bigger the gate is the more the two different
dimensions start to overlap and that's what the
mind flayer wants as dusty speculated the mind
flayer basically wants to eat other dimensions
consume or absorb other dimensions into the upside
down his own dimension who do we know that wants
to take over the world the mind players so if the
demogorgon was just his foot soldier feckness his
five-star general that's why even though they're
hyping up number one trying to get his revenge
for everything to happen to him like coming into
the real dimension and killing all these people
eventually killing brenner too it sounds like
the mind flare might have been waiting for this
opportunity and just manipulating him this whole
time to try and do that so that it can fully
piggyback itself like physically exist in the
normal dimension and take it over just like the
upside down because every time in previous seasons
when we see the mind flare we just see aspects of
it or things that it controls acting in the normal
dimension like you have the demogorgon during
season one then you have the demo dogs during
season two the mind flare starts pushing more of
itself more of the upside down into the normal
dimension during season three of that giant flesh
puppet that was being controlled by the mind flare
was sort of like an aspect of the mind flare so to
speak or like an avatar of it but we haven't seen
the actual mind flayer physically come into the
normal dimension yet just going through the scenes
in the trailer at the beginning here this seems
like brenner during the 1970s when she opened the
first gate and this is the remnants of what she
just did as a young girl closing the gate behind
number one after she pushed him in the upside down
initially then there's another scene of what looks
like max during the events of season four part
one like this seems like a flashback to part one
even though brenner's voiceover is him talking to
11 about being scared obviously it's meant to be
that kind of vibe with every different group on
the series everybody is feeling really weird it
sounds like brenner's trying to keep 11 from going
back to hawkins or helping her friends with fekna
and remember it's not just the vegna he also has
enough power to control most of the lesser forces
of the upside down even though technically those
are meant to come from the mind flayer like we
see him controlling the demo bats we also see him
controlling the demo dogs as well in the trailer
then when you see nancy fighting a version of
vecna inside the hawkins lab the weird thing
is you see all these people look like they've
just been killed but it's hard to tell if this
is happening in the real world or if this is
a flashback and it's just more of the vision
that she was getting from vecna during season four
part one like we all feel like he's going to step
through one of the gates he will make it into
hawkins like the finale is titled piggyback so
it's all about the upside down stuff piggybacking
into the normal dimension so eventually they will
make it into the normal dimension but so much of
the ending during part one was nancy getting all
these visions of vecna's backstory so it's hard
to tell if this is just more of that or if this
is happening in present day and he's made it back
we get a little bit more from will there wasn't
a whole lot going on with him during the first
part of the season they just set up this whole
mystery painting like it was going to be some big
reveal about himself but it also sounded like it
was going to be tied to the big reveal or how
they end things during season four because even
though it seems like he's kind of taken a back
seat recently it's always seemed like will's
had a special connection with the mind flayer and
what's going on in the upside down just in general
so you can let me know how you think that will is
going to help them defeat vecna during the finale
max still walking around with her headphones
and her tape player just in case she needs to
listen to more of that kate bush just keep it on
the ready just in case this is a scene of eddie
grabbing his electric guitar because it sounds
like inside the upside down they play heavy metal
music to just confound the demo bats and just the
forces of the upside down so they get confused
early theory is that it winds up being a riff on
something that their band plays and it's just a
big pop culture deep cut most of the music during
stranger things are meant to be pop songs from the
80s we get a little more footage of hopper's
group in russia and like i said this is just
them looking at the remnants of the russian gate
remember the russians tried to open a gate at the
beginning of season 3 unsuccessfully at the time
and that's why they came to the united states
created the mall and tried to use the mother
gate it sounds like whatever they were doing
during season four just weakened the barriers
so even though the russians gate initially was
unsuccessful it cracked open just enough to weaken
the barrier and now you see what's going on here
a lot of people worried about steve's life during
the finale but i do think that all the mains will
make it into season five a real big reminder there
is gonna be a season five they said there would be
a bigger time jump than there was between season
three and season four just to accommodate the
actors ages and i think what we're all expecting
is they'll defeat vegna somehow during these last
two episodes but the threat of the mind player
will be like the main villain during season five
in both the upside down and the normal dimension
will overlap so much that they'll kind of combine
into one so the entire planet will start to
look like you see in hawkins here like it'll get
way worse presumably then when they pick up during
season five episode one they'll just existed in
this sort of combined state with the upside down
just spilling into the normal dimension and just
trying to fight everything and stay alive it'll be
like walking dead in the stranger things universe
we're living in an upside down apocalypse it
sounds like max lucas and his sister going
to the krill house will have something
to do with defeating vecna and doing it
at his house like that will probably be central to
getting rid of him during the finale otherwise why
would they need to go back to his house you also
see lucas fighting the rest of the football team
at the krill house so it sounds like they follow
him there or try to find out what's going there
thinking that they're doing something crazy and
not really understanding what's going on with
vector and the upside down the whole subplot
with the football team going off the rails and
thinking that dungeons and dragons is evil heavy
metal music is evil all that stuff is very hit
or miss like either you enjoy that stuff or you
just find it kind of annoying personally i would
have rather they spent more time with some of
the other characters like they spent a lot of
time in the episodes on those football characters
we also see what looks like 11 inside the upside
down version of vecna's house like that red
space where you see him take all of his victims
whatever she winds up doing to defeat
him it will happen inside this space
remember is very freddy krueger nightmare on elm
street dream warriors kind of vibe to the season
that was the whole point in having the robert
anglin cameo during the season they had freddy
krueger cameo during the series because number one
and vecna have so many freddy krueger vibes to him
so they're really just trying to hype up the
finale ending in a giant wizard battle between
11 with her upgraded powers in vecna who seems
like he's got a couple power upgrades too the
last season i know there's a bunch of questions
about what's going on with number eight is she
gonna come back and help out i talked about that
during my last video i'm not expecting her during
these final two episodes but she might show up
during season five it feels like they're a couple
hanging plot threads across all the seasons and
they'll try to answer all those questions during
season five because that's supposed to be the
final season there are also a bunch of other
questions people had about what was going on with
mk ultra the other participants what was going on
with the upside down the mind flayer i answered
some of those during my previous video so i'll
link that at the end of this too everyone post all
your theories in the comments below only have a
couple weeks to wait before they drop the final
episodes my next big video will be my obi-wan
kenobi episode 6 finale video make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss that
everyone click here for that other brand new
stranger things season 4 volume 2 trailer video
and click here for my brand new thor love and
thunder trailer video with the guardians of the
galaxy thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!